how are you i'm fine how are you i'm
good i haven't seen you in a while i
know since like august or something um
have you have a good thanksgiving i had
a great thanksgiving um my brother david
was in town so we got to celebrate it
together oh that's nice and he's a he's
also a very funny author he's all right
no he's yeah he's really funny also and
he did the david letterman show and uh
and it was great he was really funny and
it was really a nice segment and then my
father called after we ate and was like
you look terrible you have no
personality you blew it you blew it
where are those bow ties i gave you it
was so funny
who calls up their son after he's
appeared on a talk show and says you did
horribly my father hercules
it was great he meant it a nice way
though yeah oh yeah i'm sure that's just
what you want to hear on thanksgiving
now uh who i know you're you cook yes i
do um all the time does your does your
who else cooks in your family like does
your brother cook we all cook but we
cook different things you know what i
mean like my little brother paul the
rooster he cooks like um like he has a
freezer full of food like like let's say
he has some frozen chicken wings then
he'll take him out and i'll bust him
apart with the heel of his foot and put
some hope's barbecue sauce on and stick
it in the broiler and then he'll eat
what he can and he'll throw it out in
the trash can then two hours later he'll
go out and get it pick through the trash
can like a raccoon and push it off but i
like it i'll bust it open with you wait
he'll go back if he's already thrown it
out inside you've done that haven't you
no i've not you've never thrown
something out and then gone back with
some flan once yes
and then it was i just went and scooped
it out and then
i fought a raccoon for it no
no i never did that
now um whenever you're on the show
you're very good with crafts yes i am
you just you just are it's what you do
it's one of your talents uh you're very
good with the crafts you you you brought
some what did you bring today because
there's a wall going on i i brought some
crafts that you might want to make since
it's hard times yeah so um oh first of
all my little brother wanted me to give
you a t-shirt from his floor sending
business okay this is from his floor
sanding business yeah you know silly p
hardwood floors oh so um i should hold
this up so he gets some business who
knows yeah
sedaris hardwood floors check it out
through isn't that nice oh wait look
it's on the back here though check
quality let's get this guy in the bag
well at christmas every year paul makes
you my little brother makes me something
called the pocket bucket and what it is
what the hell you take a bunch wait back
it up
okay all right all right and you fill it
with candy and just stuff that'll make
you happy so when you're feeling down
you just reach back and grab your fist
don't [ __ ] oh you didn't write
it out i thought a minute you wrote it i
wrote pocket pocket just in case ratings
so i thought and so the idea is that if
things if you're feeling down you can
just say blanket back yeah
and you reach all right
i just gave you
i just gave you an audible cue to start
saying blanket you know not you amy um
you had to go for the glory you got
potatoes you stick pencils in it for a
pencil holders what
baby shoes make really nice ashtrays for
the holidays if you've got a little
baby shoe down there what you just put
it out there
yeah that's really weird
the wishbone from like the turkey i
saved it and put a rubber band for like
slingshots for the children
to make it making these cuts these are
the i'm sorry these are the worst crafts
i've ever seen
what are these they're just you just
attacked this potato with some pencils
and called it a crab
look what i did
you can clean out your hairbrush and
make candles what did you put in the uk
bucket watch y'all um why did you
there's candy and stuff and then there's
gillette good news razors wow
what the hell is like i'm gonna kick
back and enjoy myself i can't deal it
can be full of anything what
that's crazy i'm still calling my house
and ordering cheese balls so i thought
i'd teach you how to make a cheeseburger
you know i will attest to this you've
been on the show before and you brought
your smoked chicken
and they're okay and they're great
they're delicious and you're kind of uh
known throughout manhattan for these
great cheese cheese balls and you're
going to show us how to make i'm going
to teach you how to make it let's do it
right now this will be fine let's run
over here
okay first of all you want to put
something on to protect your head so i
put on a fall what's this you're gonna
put on a hair that's what i do at home
when i was told that rehearsal this
would be a hair neck
they didn't say it would be a wig so i
just put something on my head how does
this protect my it just makes you look
good about you know feel good about
yourself and you look really pretty
[Laughter]
two-toned then you're gonna wanna feel
like i'm in the band creed
[Laughter]
with house
[Laughter]
[Applause]
okay those guys take themselves very
serious all right
whatever some people are doing
yeah we've got very little time here so
we've got to do this real fast you're
going to grate your your smoked gouda
like that okay
you want to do anything or do you want
me to okay you're going to break that
you're going to take two 8 ounce
packages of cream cheese there okay
you're going to it doesn't look too
healthy by the way a stick of butter
stick of butter that's always good dick
cheney loves it all right let's go
okay then when you get all that grated
you're gonna add it to the bowl right
you're gonna add some steak a1 sauce
that's the secret i bet that's what
gives it the smoky flavor damn right
then you're gonna add
a little bit of milk yeah okay and then
i use a blender but we don't have one
right now but you're gonna mix our show
is so low grade we can't have a blender
i love that then last night at three in
the morning i crushed some walnuts and
made some that so you throw those in
there uh no then you're gonna form a
ball and you're gonna roll it in this
this crushed nut mixture okay how do you
make the ball
well if you had grated the cheese like
you were supposed to yourself cigarette
at all and form a ball or do you want to
just form a ball oh i guess it's all my
fault that's your fault
you are the worst
and then what this is the finished one
show them what a finished one yeah so
then it's gonna look like this and then
you can decorate it and then the guy
people come over to my apartment and
pick it up for twenty dollars
do you sell them out of your apartment
yeah
you just have like a there's gonna be a
sting operation where you're illegally
selling cheese balls out of your
apartment that's great it's 20 bucks all
right well that's nice and people can
make this i think yeah i think we just
taught nobody nothing with this segment
right here
i don't think anybody learned anything
from that but it got us both looking
crazy that's the important thing
uh wonder of the world is now playing at
the manhattan theater club right here in
new york city sleeps 2 50.
sleeps 2 50. yeah
i don't know anymore amy sedaris we'll
be right back mike lupe is here